coffee on a Tuesday in blood 10 we made
it
okay everybody let's play
what the fuck is going on in your okay
so sovereign debt also known as
government debt is money or credit owed
by a central government issue bonds also
known as security basically it's like me
handing you a piece of paper and saying
I want to borrow 1 million dollars from
you and I'll pay it back in two years
let's take a look at you okay
well-dressed well-spoken good-looking
okay I'll do it
I'll give you a million dollars but only
if you pay me back a little bit extra in
return but I thought we were friends
there are no friends in finance okay how
much do you want I want my million back
plus three percent a little bit okay
where do I sign right here government's
do the same thing they dish you
sovereign bonds and accrue sovereign
debt such bonds are usually referred to
as risk-free bonds because if a
government can't pay all they have to do
is raise taxes and print more money
because government's never ever default
in their debt it's practically unheard
of that a government could ever ever
ever get close to you hold on I'll get
to you first let's wind back the clocks
I've had now observe on February 7 1992
presidents and prime ministers from 12
different European countries assembled
in Maastricht Netherlands designed the
mesthri tree mustering it was the
document that led to the creation of the
European Union and the implementation of
a single currency called the euro to
join the EU countries needed to meet
strict criteria like no budget deficits
of more than 3 percent of GDP no debt
ratios of more than 60 percent of GDP an
interest rates on sovereign bonds had to
stay within 2 percent of the EU effort
remember those number on January 1st
1999 the euro was introduced in
non-physical for individual currencies
like the German mark or the Greek
drachma were locked at fixed rates
against teacher making that
insignificant subdivisions of the euro
they had to get rid of three years later
in 2002 the notes and coins of the euro
were printed and distributed and country
started the process of exchanging all
their money for year but why did they do
it
why was the Euro create what you see
most of the trade in Europe is among its
own country by removing exchange rate
risks cutting the cost of transactions
encouraging firms to trade across
international borders the Euro made the
eurozone into an area of monetary
stability day the euro is the second
most traded currency in the world behind
the dollar
through a renewed cooperation Europe
sought not only to ensure economic
stability but the international peace
and peace they got but I thought my
jokes were bad in Greece where
civilization itself was born things have
been going awry for quite some time
after the switch to the Euro the
traditionally strong Greek public sector
saw wages rise to outstanding level not
to mention that the retirement age in
Greece was very low and its benefits
very generous but these things aren't
enough to sink a whole country it was
ultimately tax evasion which did the
trick the coastal suburb of Kaveri is
home to Athens elite an apartment here
costs more than a million euros but
despite the obvious signs of wealth
officially only sixteen thousand Greeks
declared an income of more than one
hundred thousand euros on their taxes
last year when people in businesses
don't pay their taxes it limits revenue
what the country takes when the money
ran out Athens turned to other European
banks for loans soon they owned billions
of Euro and the debt kept going but how
did Greece acquire so much debt when the
guidelines of the European Union were
supposed to keep debts reined in I'm
gonna make this pencil disappear it's in
2010 it was discovered that Greece had
paid banks like Goldman Sachs hundreds
of millions of euro and fees for
arranging transactions that would hide
the actual level of borrowing this
allowed them to keep spending and accrue
more to upon the inauguration of George
Papandreou in 2009 the Greek government
revealed that its finances were far
worse than anyone expect their budget
deficit was twelve point seven percent
four times more than the euro zone's
limit the public debt was estimated at
three hundred and twenty-nine billion a
hundred and forty four percent of GD p--
in April of 2010 Standard & Poor's
decreased Greece's debt rating to the
upper levels of junk stead junk status
bitch take a look at what happened to
the interest rates of two year bonds
holy shit let's go back to that earlier
conversation but I thought we were
friends there are no friends in finance
well with the EU that's not exactly the
case adopting the Euro the countries
involved basically agree
that they would all be economic friend
and when the drunken indulgent little
brother passes out in the gutter in the
wrong part of town the responsible older
brother has to see that he gets home
same times of economic emergency
countries can usually just print more
money and accept the inflation and
devalued currency that comes along with
but the countries in the EU gave up the
right to print their own money so now
they have to depend on one and agrees is
a relatively small country in the scheme
of things a little economy compared to
German but when Greece owes money a
campaign a Portugal important will owes
money I can't pay to Spain in Spain owes
money a campaign to Germany then a
problem arises is the domino effect
people fear ripples through the EU that
can hurt comparatively stable countries
like France and Germany and even the
United States so Greece needs help to
save the euro the other countries have
ultimately decided to bail out Greece on
50 cents of every dollar that it owes
the way they sued it wasn't cheap you
ought to know you bought it this in
exchange for internal reform in the way
of harsh austerity measures no more
early retirement reduce pay for public
workers large-scale cuts to social
programs higher taxes and a staggered
repayment of the reduced debt a lot of
people in Greece think the austerity
measures are too harsh and so they've
incited protests which continue to this
day the problem with the European debt
crisis is that Greece isn't the only
country in how much does ila know 865
billion
correct how much does Spain in Italy owe
one trillion dollars each correct
who - mainly France Britain and Germany
correct and how a Germany France and
Britain going Roger well they're
struggling a bit are they correct why
because they've lent all these vast
amounts of money to other European
economies that can't possibly pay them
back correct so what are they going to
do they're going to have to bail them
out correct where are they getting the
money to do that Roger it's a good
question
I've heard but the answer to that one
how much does Portugal oh hang on a
minute what was the answer to that
earlier question just keep answering the
questions Roger so what is the long-term
solution oast of the bailout money is
coming from European financial stability
facility some want to make the EFSF a
permanent fixture in the EU for whenever
a country is in the some had suggested
that the weak countries leave the euros
others that the eurozone should be
dismantled complete whatever the
solution whatever money is going to be
put on the table that's all going to be
conditional on
serious structural reform within the
eurozone you hate to see a few bad seeds
ruin the party for everything if we
don't deal with this now soon little
Germany here won't be able to get a
nickel for his grandma enough from the
common pot let's not blow this out of
proportion you think you could steal
from us and just walk away
yeah thanks for joining us that's
another edition of what the fuck is
going on in Europe pop